got it so quiet without any audio hey
everyone hi and welcome
it's May the fourth and today we are
going to watch a bunch of FMV cutscenes
if you joined us Star Wars Celebration
day maybe you saw some of these from a
rebel assault - we also mixed in a
little bit of gameplay but we figured
for today let's just watch these as
though they were movies cut together and
skip the game part yeah we were playing
rebel song it was pretty obvious that it
was it became a chore to even play like
the game we just wanted like the meat of
it which is these again yeah really
brown breaking FMV videos and so I have
cut together
yeah rebel salt - and dark forces - yes
that one I'm really excited to watch
because I've not seen any of that like
really apart from just clicking around
to see like what it kind of looks like
right stoked I'm stoked on that one -
and having like yet again kind of
skimmed through there are a couple
actors that you actually would know of
today who you know you guys start
somewhere apparently but yeah thanks for
watching and let's just get right into
it
Esmee rebel assault - no that's the
intro god no I like the death counter we
can weaken him we can add up Derrick is
shaking his head right now today I'm
follow guys alright let's get into it
huh I should work out is it working
um our anything is going to be announced
today do you think uh as far as like
just any kind of Star Wars stuff any
Star Wars stuff I don't know uh I was
expecting like behind the scenes like I
think II W there we go look at me double
e W uh does like a lot of behind the
scenes photo stuff like upcoming Star
Wars it's kind of expecting maybe like a
gallery but you know yeah there was a
listening to the lazer time podcast it's
a bunch of like X Capcom X Games radar
folks get together they're pretty funny
they were talking about a friend who is
working on a thing that might get
announced today how cool I think it
might be game related but I'm not it's
probably not like a blockbuster thing
right it's probably something if it is a
game smaller than that but cool I don't
know I'm gonna keep an eye out and see
what they're talking about
wait a second already I have my scrub
here this is the shortest oh yeah
that's yours that's your second
paragraph an octave ater enraged by
defeat comes obsessed with the
Alliance's elimination yeah it's from
jest we uh wow it's like whoa okay yeah
dark fate so okay so he's just taking
place after the first Death Star is that
we just said ah I wasn't paying
attention let's find out Rob though oh
by the way okay
that is the best intro post-credits so I
this is like the a short NIC is way too
long
special thanks to George Lucas thank you
George so you are the life of a Shoebat
hello let's speak with me Admiral yes
tell me why I want no slip-ups this time
the demonstration shows me great
flawlessly am I understood
yes of course sir they'll be ready good
girl
it was so awkward it never did they
should have done the like wait left
right Hey even this walk you know he's
got like five feet this green screen
hell yeah it's me James Earl Jones
stigma squadron stands ready awaiting
your command
very well Admiral engage the rolls
that's pretty good classic
ok so I think this is this is an
alternate in a beginning or something uh
it's real good though
no no today's trying to turn that death
counter off do hey we're gonna count the
people that died yeah
you ruined everything dad thanks T take
one more now activate I hear you
let's make it quick I want to stay I got
a ticket oh god no no I'm loving it
no they came from hook kind my last
words to her work
no that is some crappy minute I'm into
it I was great alright two deaths so far
I'm gonna be the human death counter
Anthony Rodriguez what's happening we
are watching the FMV
why in a few years what I see is another
one of your interest tests I will not be
impressed until I have under my command
the full power to crush the rebel alive
we get it this is a nice representation
of what I would imagine Vader to be
doing with most of his time staring into
deep space just not what if not in one
of the original trilogy's be wings cool
they know what's up they know their
audience Oh
just to recap joining us this is not the
trailer for last Jedi some computer chat
we are looking at a rebel salt to when
the game come out 1992 I think 92 we're
just looking at the cutscenes of it so
right now we're skipping through
gameplay because we just really want to
watch it all the way through is good
there's about 35 minutes of this and
then 35 minutes of dark forces dark
forces to yank jet kid
horrible shock okay yeah
Baumer game dialogue is quiet I'll try
to do my best to ride the levels here
[Music]
[Laughter]
the way everyone stands and runs ice
absurd yeah I just think it's like a
space or just or or there's a horrible
director who just strolls in late just
as Chad's run what you just won takes
everything don't look so confused
doors are closing huh also behind the
bookie Falcon
I'll just go deeper into this ship then
oh man I think I showed you the other
weird I was cutting together it's not
even the right controls with the Falcon
they've no range looks like it's got
like a handbrake emergency Egret and
just puts it forward and that's it too
loud my bad sorry and that's it huh yeah
there's a lot of gameplay we're missing
obviously well I mean that you could say
that's a little bit of a meet and story
but what is it so far so far I'm
gathering he crash-landed found the
Falcon and he's off
now ah this is pretty that's that big
this is unorthodox
[Laughter]
[Music]
Wow Eric Zelda superstar Schreyer we are
cruising through this game
Welch
you know didn't even shoot anything Oh
cuz it's the gameplay this is actually
so unfortunately I'd say this game is
hard to watch without the gameplay
because it's just not very good no no
it's not very coherent at all this game
doesn't even make sense with gameplay
what I say really all you're doing it
doesn't I don't know I'm getting add
this is happening so cool
well I think what the thing is is that
we're getting caught up in a lot of
these quick little space transitions the
cooling system without yeah yeah we'll
go quick yes that's the plan okay I
remember this much this is the Getti
sense where would that go good i watch
this one sighs we will end it where is
this other x-wing who is he and where is
he going
sorry
okay no no I did not understand that
there has to be some fanfiction about
that guy the real road sure that the one
road the ice cream maker guy no that one
they flying out of a giant meatball it
wasn't done yet Peter come on [ __ ]
okay
let's go home okay oh so okay so I don't
understand this part other than I think
that these are rebels who have stolen
TIE fighters right okay you do the
Emperor knew you would if you know the
guys like know get a text from Palpatine
what was that
[Music]
if you're just joining us we were
watching rebel salt to all the cutscenes
hi how are you hello again
Dubonnet they couldn't even go a real
forest fall by pterodactyl
as you know hmm no no we need more of
this
giant flying thing it's real cool Oh
[Music]
so I've ever seen this what yeah no I'm
sorry since when was the superstars
Troyer uh using cloak or in any form
design Star Trek Robert oh right
don't you know they're set in the same
universe the cgi artists doing two
different eggs at once who's also doing
Star Trek slub oh yes
it's like see now the audio gets really
weird here
yeah apologies sorry
I mean that that's legit that would make
sense as a stormtrooper Oh
yes mr. Bobo tom says uh dark forces is
better than everything we're good we're
getting there I really want to get to it
so that was a whole zine of like yet
really crappy night-vision shooting Oh
another jackin this tie fire I don't
know that what what I know the name of
this tie fighter
how's it the Interceptor the Interceptor
had just two wings like they look like
this one this one's got three whoa
perfect
[Music]
oh so this alright maybe this is a
different star story then they're gonna
blow I've never seen this [ __ ] like that
oh okay but no that's a super
stardestroyer that the Matteson returned
a Jedi so one that like goes into but
they've made more than one up something
like a look at that looks strange for me
but good I want to sure fine cloak the
reactor cool could go critical at any
time disengage from space dog
we cannot my don't disengage from space
stock I mean it just got a bit just drop
it falsely so belligerent oh wait he was
on that ship I guess so and it's about
to blow up
oh that's so cool the hell it was a
space dock are they going back no Vader
escapes they're going in
they're going back to the future I don't
know what this that was the same shot
what the hell so they went back to the
space station after they were leaving
and it closed Wow
oh it's a Thai Phantom thanks good
enough
can't 600 that was awesome
now blow the whole thing up I can't wait
until this one blows up oh I remember
what I had to do I pulled the first file
as I pulled were all stripped of music
and and so this is the last clip cos was
longer of the whole outro robbed someone
saying that was the superstar of
destroyed terror okay that could cloak
oh cool I'm glad someone is uh yeah
that's awesome but Star Wars fans are in
the chat yeah yeah not bad all right
see there's no audit there's no music
and it's horrible well kid I didn't
think you had it in you thank you sir
looks like the Alliance owes you a debt
of gratitude without the advantage of
their phantom fleet the Empire will have
to face us on equal ground once again
you've saved us all of course I've
survived tougher missions than this in
my day you little [ __ ] man no thanks to
you lady forget it oh that's about it oh
no there's more I think there's more
yeah there's definitely more yeah
there's no way we've gotten to the first
one yet
hell yeah heavy living me Toretto
yes my master the rebels have proven
surprisingly clever but we are not
defeated ah such good exposition so good
what did we learn what did we learn
there all right let me cut out to camera
for a quick second I thought this was a
little bit longer it is I think it is
actually um I just tripped down some
stuff no I didn't mean to to be lost it
was like it was extremely hard to find
like we were looking at the original
files member that yeah we were trying to
find a way to play the original files
using all sorts of stuff like the
scummvm emulator but this is all kind of
last-minute it couldn't happen but
anyway we are here I think for the best
person yeah yeah that start forces to
for sure and this is the real meat
because archive.org has the original
actual thing smk right I don't know the
files from the game and so someone was
like I convert them all to mp4 here you
go all of them so I put them all in
order and I didn't I know it's about
dark forces is that there's an alternate
ending for the dark side great so we're
going to see it all
oh this is gonna get but we have to look
up the IMDB of this too so I can name
know these actors that's a different
font already
[Music]
Oh help tests on the chat well time for
Susie
oh yeah okay cool
all right
Dark Jedi Oh drek drek Derek Derek is a
jerk
did you know that's actually Matthew s
Pinellas first name that's possible
Valley of the Jedi I wasn't joking I
know you know I gotta remember that lost
battleground okay
[Music]
Steve s no we are not actually playing a
game we were just watching FMV from old
Star Wars games because they probably
aren't that fun to play today
it's also at least rebel assault to
isn't sure and it's also a factor of
time I thought we just get all the story
in oh yeah calamitous Corvette this is
this is a nice twist
whoa that's all
excuse me sorry whoa
all right these are slightly off
although honestly this is stretched to
sixteen by nine right that might be part
of the problem is these are definitely
four by three Mickey Mouse can I
accidently export this instruction no I
don't think so man I think I did I think
I suggested oh hell yeah I thought if
anyone knows that ship I would love to
know the name of it oh this guy is that
Billy Dee no what's not Billy Dee
Williams is it
we got can you add King Louie I have the
item buyers of dysphoria
I am DB strike me down and time wrong
kiss him you know that I don't know why
I thought that's beliefs that's
obviously not him
that terry gilliam look at dude what is
he wearing around his eyes smelling him
stop farting log on guitar this dead man
knows the balance location you've got
something on your oh very intriguing
yeah what two kids Jack Nicholson get so
pretty all right so the bad man is
Christopher NIEM
don't know him
oh yeah that's a different Oh
[Music]
Jia bene
that's what we're looking at okay
Bennett Guillory oh he just wouldn't all
he's got here you've been super saiyan
holy [ __ ]
what is he doing to him are you doing to
him I just want to say that that
lightsaber that one dude had was legit I
was a nice take on this a bird he's just
looked like a steak for two bronze
we in course op no it's so blocky and
just little eyes I think this looks
great goodness what is our perspective
will be upside down
what is upside
[Music]
hahaha how very proud I am of you
what a fine young man you've become
I wish your mother were here to see it
but I know she watches over you and his
proud that's a good thing I record
before they had this position when
someone desires information they come to
me don't waste my time idiot tell me who
killed my father patience he is a Dark
Jedi gener Dark Jedi
he is known as Jarek and he has great
plans for the rebirth of the Empire I'm
not interested in petty political
struggles well you should be without
going into too much detail Jarek has
been quite generous in his offerings
unfortunately you don't factor into them
oh so this is just like a like a heart
jabba the hutt me like yes sure he's
been generous [ __ ] them dead father's
for you anyway
right I can decipher any language or
code no but this one indels me it must
be important it's kind of a song to
indulge this that's alright dark side
I've been there
Oh do your worst
I am loving this well I suppose that
concludes our business there's you
didn't look that bad no that looks great
I'm not interested in leaving I have
some business to conclude with your
friend 88 Isis miles ahead salt that's
for damn sure
okay hell yeah oh there goes oh he's
flying at lambda shuttle all right
stolen draw this is just that he's her
he reels
we're in space now Oh whenever I need to
find you you always in some kind of
sweet got really authorized what would
you do without me Kyle I'd be a Content
old man somehow I don't see content or
an old man so much for the relaxing chat
Jan meet me the top I've got to get that
disc I looked away wear her goggles on
and then when they cut back they're all
she she keeps putting her goggles on
when this can come up this I'm not sure
I want to say 97 that's all I say to you
hmm oh yes dream sequence yeah I guess
I hope he's standing atop of that
plateau shirtless is it talking to him
he searches for the location of a sacred
place a ballet
a forceful house Jedi just come if
captured this is power he will be a
creature such as the universe has never
sent a supernova of stars dark forces to
is indeed a 1997 video game I was
correct
oh sorry sorry Steve looks like it is 97
you boy father it's okay but this crew
has no possessions remember remember it
will be your path bright out of the way
so that worked out well you're blessed
ship is going to be in the repair Bay
for the next few days
look nothing that a crate full of money
ways you don't have win solve like
always I owe you did you take care of
her for me you're not going out to
Jericho you know I'm going back to my
father's home and so on can you meet me
there when you're finished with the crow
of course is everything okay I don't
know
I'll find out when I get wasn't that
thing a lot bigger before I love it I
have to see that again because that's
gonna be your new desktop backer - that
is clam I'm just gonna sup I just love
how the directors like trust me on this
he's like alright I got something no
I'll find out when I get ya that is so
Star Wars though that's awesome that's
really cool I'm not even messing around
someone like really went for it
there's that stolen wave the shuttle
[Music]
what's the last update now what do we do
8088 will decisive that baby idiot idiot
alright calm okay this is pre calm an
inspiration that's right what is this
guy imagine imagine that was a friend of
yours
oh look is like really funny but that's
what he every year for Halloween you
need Association never breaks character
ah
supposed to got Resident Evil cutscene
like the original original bad CG damn
Wow
Wow got to another planet Oh every time
you hold that up I'm just going to
expect a planet I was just like praise
gonna drill into exam is this thing work
me was it on Kyle Kyle I have left two
very important items the first is a map
to the valley of the Jedi and is
embedded in the stone ceiling about this
room the whole ceiling
the last is a lightsaber that once
belonged to a friend it feels like he
doesn't know where the camera lens is
like shouldn't he know where to look I'm
gonna make the map hard to find but
here's the lightsaber no problem it will
work breaking apart the ceiling man
that'd be so cool like have that
cutscene and then just get the saver now
you got it
that's it that's it now you're rocking
it
[Music]
was this factorial
just a joke
[Music]
there is gotcha yep enhance Baron said
the employer knows how to ruin a
perfectly good city my guess is your pal
88 is in that large house the Imperials
are guarding it like a fortress well I
think a visits in order don't you I want
to look up this one guy I think we're
gonna see soon he was an Amadeus Oh
[Music]
thank you yeah you ever
[Music]
well I'm missing out here oh my god the
body of the Jedi will soon be mine it's
like a Mortal Kombat character mm-hmm
your payment is waiting with you and one
of my cargo ships meat into a refueling
station outside of bounds
mmm vengeance 500 space
what a weird-looking chip
I should have been for you
I had a chance got him lost opportunity
I want the map 88 all yours Kyle
I hear ya whoa
I'm not gonna lie I was kind of like a
wiener what is he what this is a Mortal
Kombat character in all my years I've
only known looks like scorpion but weird
somehow I expected
[Music]
Jimmy isn't that what you do to Dark
Jedi
[Music]
I'm wrong it's not Amadeus
No Wolfgang Mozart I thought that it's a
name would be Tom whole Susana what
watching
time
we had a saber thank God he needs no
training without not all everytime that
ships finding it play cricket hmm it's
got like a flat tyre
character's name is yarn I'm here yeah
miles deserve payment Rafer Weigel you
know
as seen in I am Sam yeah if memory
serves you right so uh or Bobo Tom yeah
you can kill or not kill that guy
which I don't finally get my chance to
repay you
ah yes our master is on the way to the
valley you will not be so lucky to
experience all right I love it
oh good point d jdz the truth you do
train in the game it's been a while
what you doin twenty years so the point
of this game is that you're becoming you
know Jedi and you kind of get to pick
your path a little bit so the training
happens oh there was training yeah cool
back when this was first coming out it
was still in development like the
controls of the lightsaber were a really
big deal could you do first or third
person since I was seeing both both like
I thought I saw I thought I think you
might be right
I saw like both types of gameplay yeah
or maybe they were just specific scene I
mean third person I know for sure yeah I
feel like there was also an option for
first if not maybe in Jedi Knight
Academy
all right more MORE
well alright
transition
James Carmichael we're not playing the
game because we're just trying to see
the whole story and obviously we can't
do that during one live stream so yeah
we I we also just really wanted to see
these cutscenes yes and maybe we can
find a little bit of lore or something
that could lead us to more info on last
Jedi a so I was really hoping yeah
[Music]
oh it's a dangerous ledge let's land on
him
so you vote
[Music]
come on what are we doing
[Music]
first try oh but then they're going to
land separately the valley is being
prepared for you my lord
very good
oh hell yeah
I think someone was saying that that's
her brother got in the middle or
actually maybe I'm wrong someone
somebody in this or they're brother and
sister
[Music]
man they're drawing I know I know I love
it right
just so they can meet that half hour
you're dead like half hour with the
cutscenes you asked for it
go on fight me on it jerks men they've
already gotten their hooks into this
place I've got to get to the top of that
Tower
you're just gonna get into more trouble
that's when you bail me out I think you
cut mm-hmm you know what Kyle no I'm not
gonna bail you out okay I haven't eaten
in like a week what don't say me no yes
no wait no but yes it isn't it isn't
oh you tricked taste from the for stuff
from the beginning was he in the
beginning yeah I think he got didn't you
kill him I must have missed okay
oh so you can choose a kills yeah this
is a big oh you can't can ya you're weak
like a father I remember it Jarek he
gave a sweet slow death death worthy of
a coward
I honor taking his head thrusting it on
a spike for all to see it's guys good
yeah you wanted that house a heavy scene
yeah excellent Katan you've started your
journey to the dark side now kill this
woman you love so much looks like I
can't bail you out of trouble this time
sheikha down and realize your true
destiny as a dark jedi your true power
yes
that's all it took was one death for him
to actually get the point raised like
yeah maybe I'll kill my best friend
again
I like this pale dude I kind of wanna
hang out with him more often then you
will die
[Music]
whoops
my bad
you think it's gonna fall
yeah
it was probably some gameplay you're
falling on the ship yeah clearly
Oh
Yap ship was falling you're running
through it cool cause you kinda wanna
see that oh such a bad fall but you'll
be glad to know I found your lightsaber
and they give you a blood transfusion
with my blood
[Laughter]
Oh Rock not so distinctive now is it
haha tell Jared but this Jedi will soon
join the dead what were like guys doing
now what if he got much work after yeah
this dude was born the same year as
Woodstock the event 1969 really yeah he
does I have a hard time believing that
looks so young yeah
oh whoops deserves a battle that's it
was my favorite I was so awkward
Oh worse no yeah I think this is an
alternate I just did them all in order
however I had it how the game laid it
out
punch it
[Music]
I think we're gonna see maybe I did this
weird but like we're gonna see two
timelines at the same time I guess okay
that makes sense sure I didn't want to
spoil myself
[Music]
in the valley in the temple
oh my god his [ __ ] scrotum oh god I
guy
[Music]
okay
Oh
I was taking a dip
[Music]
don't disturb me that was awesome
I'll be back in a sec would even call
[Music]
oh man is this look so bad oh oh what
does he got he attained enlightenment
no look look he had like a let's go back
like Oh what is he holding something or
am I just bronzers legs crossed I'm dumb
this is so weird
that's what it looks like when I take a
shower what's going on here move some
out don't be a dick she's here bold in
danger these are key cloaks oh he's like
a chameleon oh it's amazing I don't know
why the feed cuts out my sentiments I
know what I'm gonna I'm gonna do it oh
no oh no you don't don't do it
I've never seen a yellow light saber
before I know yeah well
it smells like sex in here oh yeah
that was good cool it's like wow Stefan
it up
I am defenseless strike me down and the
power of the dark side will be yours I'm
sure you haven't forgotten I was the one
murdered your father
no I haven't
oh I did thank good call that's fine
Wow that's fine
everyone just joining us in the chatons
is accomplished in cutscenes from dark
forces to and we're watching the two
alternate paths that kind of branch out
during the game so we're seeing a bit of
the light path map
yeah resolution to wrought up it did oh
it's not us
[Music]
that recipes cook it Tom
[Music]
I like what's happening here
[Music]
what that
he's on a scene here
thank you Father
it's one way to end it
thanks dad
I love you dad cat's in the cradle this
plays with the credits at the end but
hold on but wait why do I let you choose
the dogs I can take all the power of the
valley myself
screw you Jan pitchy then you will die
wait wait what wait what shouldn't he be
like nice you scrub through this a
little bit I feel like it's my p.m. and
today no I think we should leave it this
is good I want to see the ship fall
again uh yeah yes rebel scum yes doc
welcome Tian he loved das scrotum
I have another patch for you haha
scrotum
[Music]
where's the front landing gear cozy
I'm spies free base down I have no time
for petty uprisings extinguisher my wing
yes I want to see this note no actually
now I want to hear it again spy spring
word of a small rebel uprising on dinner
I have no time for petty uprisings
extinguish them painfully yes Oh is the
Emperor just like that
we're those goblins look at that boring
and have fun Emperor yeah just how you
like it told me there be ESPN where's
the team team oh I was expecting a
Keurig in here I need some coffee and
call my assistant I want you to remember
some but you're at the academy how very
proud I am of you
ooh did he make the right choice
delete strong foot that's it
is that it I think that's it all right
that was funny nice just about ready to
a call at 12 o'clock all right well near
the fourth may the fourth be with you
guys thank you guys for watching that uh
whatever that was whatever that was I
had a good time I've been mean to comb
through those awesome FMV videos thank
you Peter my pleasure and thank you guys
again for hanging out stay tuned
later I think around 1 o'clock we're
going to be streaming a little game
called prey that's right let's go to
prey I'm Brent thank you guys bye bye
great rest of the week I made it fall
off day with you